o sol
boa tarde eu vou a convidá los a fazer
uma viagem no tempo de pensar naquela
pequena esquadra e poucos na vizinhos
que entrou nessa bahia 450 anos atrás
comandada pelo jovem capitão e do
deslumbramento que muitos que estavam
viajando pela primeira pela primeira vez
as montanhas as matas tudo aquilo não
janeiro
vamos imaginar que fosse um dia de sol
colocar o marco de fundação da cidade e
perder a vida
no dia seguinte a uma maneira talvez de
morrer feliz com a mais bela das imagens
e passar para a posteridade como
fundador da nossa cidade do rio de
janeiro possivelmente foi quem viu a
baía de guanabara da melhor maneira
desde então acho que a cada dia ela
piora a cada dia o homem agride com essa
paisagem natural e um pouco em cima
dessa reflexão naturalmente acompanhando
outras experiências ao longo do mundo é
que eu tenho os últimos tempo batalhado
pela constituição tudo uma entidade que
se chama uma autoridade de bahia para
ordenar as coisas na baía de guanabara
mas a ordenar a baía de guanabara no
fundo você está coordenando a região
metropolitana
e isso é o que eu espero deixar então
claro aqui primeiro que uma coisa
implica na outra e se nós estamos num
momento que eu sei que se pensa uma vez
mais ressuscitar um órgão o
metropolitano é o momento de talvez as
duas coisas juntas
a ação eficaz na bahia
entendo que passa por esse tipo de órgão
que desenho institucional é muito
singular que a bahia tem muitos donos
capitania dos portos da marinha de
guerra
o estado e as suas secretarias de
ambiente e vários outros a cedae os
municípios não são um são 15 cada um
como sei quantas secretarias já se estou
mais de 200 entidades que têm alguma
coisa a ver proteção à pesca incentivo
ao turismo
tudo conversa para essa bahia e ao
pensar numa maneira de abordar e da
racionalidade para que essas medidas
sejam eficazes
a gente bate realmente e com vai ser um
cão serão os valores qual vai ser a meta
que eu diria até mais do que isso
convencer a religião dessa entidade é
iluminar pela sustentabilidade nas suas
dimensões não só ambientais mas sociais
e econômicas
eu vou deixar que a bahia a época do
descobrimento e falar de algumas
experiências internacionais sobre a
autoridade de bahia são francisco bl nos
estados unidos nasceu
justamente do que estava falando a quem
pretendeu aqui a exposição da
coordenação do transporte na área da
grande baía de são francisco que vocês
têm na imagem é lá que está a golden
gate
é lá que está o clã grid
ou seja é uma geografia complexa mas por
outro lado onde talvez primeiro
experimentou uma enorme coordenação das
modalidades de transporte
já na transa pique bem do outro lado ea
jusante do rio potomac que banhou
washington
o problema era a poluição química das
águas que estava eliminando a vida então
e isso passou inclusive por drenagem e
dragagem de vastas áreas mas conseguiu
se limpar daí a reabilitar a vida
selvagem a vida natural e assim na
europa existem exemplos do rio tâmisa aí
seu estuário do rio tejo seu estuário e
muitos outros em outros lugares do mundo
e que permitem lhes afirmar que pensar a
região metropolitana é pensar a baía de
guanabara com toda a sua beleza com toda
sua multiplicidade de usos mas todos
realmente vamos dizer em excelentes
condições se alguém
enfim quando era bolso às vezes saía de
lá acha pela baía de guanabara era ainda
um lugar lindo andava-se de lancha hoje
ninguém andar de lancha macho recreio no
fim de semana mas pegar a barca até
paquetá verão uma panorama realmente
terrível
ilhota as fantásticas que são protegidas
pelo patrimônio são depósitos grande
distante da petrobras
o fundo da baía uma camada de lodo
ele chama a maionese negra cobre impede
qualquer existência de vida
a bahia está morrendo e talvez com uma
dificuldade muito maior que a
recuperação que nós vimos na lagoa de
araruama e outros
ou seja hoje ao mesmo tempo que a gente
aciona para o homem
a região metropolitana equacione para a
natureza as baías que também não é só de
guanabara também de sepetiba ilha grande
vão nessa mesma direção então a minha
reflexão sobre a forma de atuar sobre
isso concentrou se naquilo que eu fiz
durante uma boa parte da minha vida que
é no desenho de instituições adequadas e
aqui a gente começa com esse enorme
desafio que tem até hoje impedido que as
coisas avancem porque todos conhecem o
caso das estações de tratamento de
esgoto foram feitas pelo estado mas os
municípios e as concessionárias não
fizeram as redes que jogassem para as
estações de tratamento de esgoto
então você tem estações de tratamento
funcionando a 5% da capacidade e
municípios 10 por cento dos votos como
são gonçalo e como duque de caxias
então a primeira coisa é conceber uma
entidade que depois de um trabalho que
foi feito por uma consultoria da
fundação getúlio vargas foi batizada de
a autarquia transfer ativa
de acordo com a constituição
até a maneira muito usual despromover
consórcios municipais
usa-se muito pelo lixo dois ou três
municípios fazem um aterro sanitário
comum aqui no caso a pretensão é maior a
jogar
o governo federal estadual e municipal
dentro da mesma entidade e essa entidade
então ela teria a liberdade de trafegar
convocar esses agentes todos isso é
outra coisa que a gente tem que aprender
no brasil é não inventar fundir órgãos
não inventar criar redefinir e
hierarquias a autoridade nasceria como o
órgão pequeno mais 15 a 20 técnicos de
alto nível e de alta inteligência
emocional e que não ganhassem uma
atribuição do tipo você vai fazer o
plano você vai fazer o planejamento não
cada um tem que ser dona de uma meta
sua meta é a bbdo demanda bioquímica de
oxigênio na forja de cada rio que chega
na bahia sua meta é o lixo flutuante a
sua meta é a qualidade água a sua meta é
o tempo de percurso e dentro dessa
configuração traz federativa
essa facilidade de convocar eu fora o
governador presidiria a senhora não
porque no momento que se arrumar isso
você a roma
o que virou a nossa bahia uma área
cercada com 12 milhões de habitantes
chover disse eu descobri onde é um
aqui
opa
essa área aqui que vocês vêem no point é
a saída para são paulo avenida brasil
estão luiz e vai até o centro da cidade
aqui se localizam 9 milhões 75% da
população zona sul barra jacarepaguá 10
por cento tal dilema dos transportes que
a gente ouviu aqui ainda pouco e do lado
de lá são gonçalo e outros 15%
vejam bem aí que nós estamos a caminho
também de haver uma outra revolução
urbana nesse negócio com a abertura do
arco metropolitano sai mais ou menos
daqui e vem pro lado de cá então vastas
áreas muito pouco densamente ocupadas
áreas
às vezes frágeis do ponto de vista
ambiental como o manguezal de guapimirim
pra quem não conhece uma espécie de um
pantanal do rio daqui do rio de janeiro
uma profusão de aves vida selvagem
negócio realmente muito interessante
algo que pede um plano tão ambicioso
quanto da barra mas que realmente
consiga ajudar a redefinir a sua
ocupação
enfim no que diz respeito é a send
cidade o papel é aquilo que tem muitos
dons ea baía de guanabara tem uns 200
não é de ninguém uma entidade cobradora
de resultados com transparência
seria realmente me parecem a maneira
mais efetiva e mais leve a gente começar
a obter
importante avanço nessa área de
prioridade essa entidade estariam na
disseminação de transparência da
informação necessária na identificação
das áreas de risco que isso realmente já
se discutiu eu mesmo participei de um de
um grupo de trabalho ministerial criado
depois daqueles desastres foram os
deslizamentos de encosta e não da ação
em petrópolis há uns três anos atrás
quer dizer a chegada do verão é a
certeza de dezenas e dezenas de morte em
geral de idosos e de crianças que até
mostra um lado vou dizer um lado
estranho da natureza humana tão
dedicadas às crianças agentes ficam à
solta nessas horas que quando ocorre o
acidente são os que têm menos defesas
então a primeira prioridade seria
eliminar todas as habitações em áreas de
risco e isso impõe mudanças
remanejamentos ou obras de proteção
saneamento básico já discutido aqui a
gestão dessas bacias desses rios
essa gestão quer dizer são rios curtos
que nascem aqui na serra do mar
isso tem que vir de cima para baixo
realmente um trabalho de desenvolvimento
de bacia de educação ambiental e a
partir do momento que chega realmente
nas áreas mais densamente povoadas
aí as formas clássicas de enfim de
canalização de proteção e outras
cabíveis
o rio de janeiro a paisagem natural do
rio é tombada é
faz parte do patrimônio da humanidade da
unesco catalogado
essa paisagem em vários cantos da cidade
em vários ângulos mostra profundas
alterações pela ação do homem
há também aí um trabalho a ser feito de
reconstituição disso e por fim a gestão
do território ea criação de soluções de
mobilidade como a gente já viu zé é uma
entidade então que trabalha como se diz
nos estados unidos na agenda negativa é
verificar os jobs as dificuldades e
retirá las em vez de querer reinventar a
roda
então se alguém está querendo limpar um
rio
o que é necessário para isso alguns
casos apoio técnico de outros casos são
fomentar movimentos de base em outros
casos pode depender de dinheiro de
financiamentos bds de bi disso daquilo
enfim é uma maneira de fazer as coisas
acontecerem e eu queria que acabar nós
falando um pouco sobre isso não traz
possibilidades que essa entidade permite
a primeira que em função da mudança do
perfil demográfico e econômico da região
metropolitana
nós caminhamos para ter uma população
mais idosa em vez de mais um hospital em
vez de mais escolas e por outro lado com
uma correção na concentração de renda o
que também já houve aqui algumas
indicações importante hoje comentava de
manhã que esse movimento todo da
indústria de petróleo
de certa maneira fez o rio destoar do
resto
tudo brasil porque concentrou-se a renda
no rio
criou-se mais empregos mais alto livro
do que o reflexo em baixo é um ponto que
deve fazer parte das políticas já se
falou tanto urani estudou isso é essa é
socializar os benefícios gerais desse
desenvolvimento
e o outro tipo de reflexão que se impõe
é que as coisas estão mudando no mundo
eventos extremos estão ficando mais
comuns
a elevação do nível dos mares não é para
daqui a 200 anos
é algo já começou
dentro de 50 anos as projeções variam
entre meio metro e um metro para o
atlântico sul
isso implicará em obras especiais ao
longo das praias do rio de janeiro
diques de proteção de marés mas pode ter
um efeito devastador
se até lá nós não tivermos resolvido
esse problema de bairros inteiros na
baixada em duque de caxias são gonçalo
principalmente alguma coisa nova iguaçu
que sofrem com as marés a determinadas
combinações de naresh que a água não
escorre digamos do esgoto ela volta pra
dentro a doação unitário ou seja existem
desafios enormes e à gestão da região
metropolitana saudável implica na
reconstituição e recuperação do ponto de
vista ambiental mas também do ponto de
vista de todas as atividades plurais de
recreação do porto do rio de janeiro
enfim de do transporte de tudo isso que
a nossa baía de guanabara pode
realmente proporcionar é essa reflexão
que eu queria deixar aqui nessa tarde
muito obrigado